SPEAKER: Managing services
is complex, especially
in multicloud environments.
Your application teams
have an increasing number
of services and
hybrid deployments
that they have to
manage as you scale.
As the network information of
instances dynamically change,
your applications must
be able to quickly find
the most up-to-date
information of your services.
These systems are time
consuming and challenging
to run without a single place to
publish, discover, and connect
all your services, which
can lead to increased
complexity of management and
operations of your applications
and having to use your valuable
engineering team's time
to manually store, track,
and update resource name
and end point information,
or make changes directly
within the application code.
Even with your best
efforts, these systems
can still fail as
your services grow.
Customers want to be able to
take a service-centric, rather
than an infrastructure-centric,
approach
to connecting services.
We are here to help solve
this pain point with Service
Directory from Google Cloud.
Service Directory will
reduce the complexity
of your application deployment,
allowing all of your services
to be understood across
multicloud environments,
increasing the productivity
of your development teams.
Service Directory
helps consumers
keep track of their
services as they scale,
regardless of your environment.
As a fully managed
offering, Service Directory
frees you from having to install
software and manage instances
as you scale.
You won't have to worry
about feature upgrades
or incompatible software.
We will make sure it
stays up and running
so you are not impacted.
Service Directory will
provide real time information,
whether you have a few end
points or thousands, enabling
you to register and resolve
them by a DNS, HTTP, and gRPC.
Define your services
with customer names
and rich metadata,
allowing you to group
them while making
your end points
easily understood by your
consumers and applications,
increasing your
application reachability.
Rich permissions ensures
that only the correct teams
at your organization
will have the ability
to update or look
up these services.
So your application
developers won't
have to worry about accidentally
impacting other teams.
Best part of all,
Service Directory
is deeply integrated with
other Google services,
helping you simplify
your service management
and operations
across environments.
Learn more about how having
a single place to publish,
discover, and connect
all your services
can benefit your business
at cloud.google.com.